[Music]
just a little fact about color you know
when we say for example that a leaf
is green we say it is green which kind
of implies that it's an inherent
property of the thing itself but a leaf
is green not because anything in it is
green but because it is rejecting the
green that is it is receiving from
sunlight the white light of the sun is
composed of all colors red orange yellow
green blue violet green is in there so
in come all the colors
and the leaf says i don't want your
green and it bounces it back out to the
rest of the world the green is the very
color that this isn't yet
conversationally we say the leaf is
green i just thought i'd share that with
you and it's true for all the colors a
red apple is rejecting the red light
incident upon it and that is this state
of the world